Facciamo un esperimento
fingiamo di essere bimbi e di trovarci
per la prima volta di fronte alla parola
gelato e di riuscire a leggerla
immaginate le emozioni immaginate le
sinapsi nel cervello che si scatenano
immaginate il desiderio di parlare
Voglio il gelato di muoversi il gusto
immaginate adesso di essere capaci per
la prima volta di scrivere la parola
gelato Ecco ci sarà un senso di
soddisfazioni siamo riusciti a produrre
quello che volevamo produrre l'impeto
iniziale c'era
Però come dicevo è forse più un senso di
soddisfazione che di gioia e di mondo
che ci si apre davanti
il potenziale creativo della lettura è
molto maggiore rispetto a quello della
scrittura
un da un lato Perché abbiamo delle
reazioni fisiologiche di fronte e
significati alle parole e dall'altro
perché ciò che leggiamo si può mettere
da parte per poi usarlo in altre
occasioni di creatività
leggete questa frase
Ecco in ognuno di noi subito nasce
un'idea della pioggia del ticchettio
dell'atmosfera che si crea
forse dell'odore
e a un certo punto anche la pioggia che
si interrompe lascia quel profumo della
asfalto dell'erba bagnata e il tempo che
cambia magari è il vento
una nuvola che si apre e arriva un
raggio di sole tutte queste reazioni
ognuno di noi le ha avute secondo la
propria esperienza la propria vita le
cose che desidera quello che ha
accumulato
e rappresenta in qualche modo Una specie
di inclinazione con la quale ci
avviciniamo alla lettura un po' come un
aereo che si che si avvicina che
approccia alla pista di atterraggio Però
il bello è che questa pista di
atterraggio è come se fosse su una
nuvola perché c'è oltre c'è dell'altro
io anni fa ebbi una curiosità
una scuola di scrittura creativa mi
chiese se io volessi offrire un workshop
per i suoi studenti e io arrivo
architetto più o meno E da un lato
sapevo che c'erano queste
impressioni immaginazioni idee che si
creano di fronte alla lettura dall'altro
avevo sempre sentito delle espressioni
quali l'architettura di un romanzo
oppure le fondamenta di una storia
un testo che sta non sta in piedi avevo
sempre notato come queste espressioni
fossero in realtà usate con grande
Libertà per esprimere dei concetti che
potevano servire per analizzare un testo
magari per spiegarne la struttura in
realtà
e poi avevo spesso provato una
sensazione quasi
sinestetica del mezzo della lettura di
un testo spesso magari di un romanzo ci
fermiamo un attimo e c'è quella
sensazione di essere immersi in uno
spazio invece di essere dei lettori
osservatori da fuori che guardiamo un
qualche cosa improvvisamente Puff siamo
dentro una struttura che ci si è creata
intorno quasi da sola
con queste cose in mente arrivo di
fronte agli studenti e chiedo loro Ma
scusate
se esiste se l'architettura di una
storia fosse davvero edificio
che edificio sarebbe perché non mi
prendete per mano e mi portate nelle
strutture delle storie che conoscete
così bene Fatemi vedere e non Ditemelo a
parole
il risultato dei loro lavori fu
incredibile
segno che c'era latente nascosta un
calderone di conoscenze e di creatività
dato dalle loro letture attive e
Creative al quale non so se sapevano di
avere accesso In realtà avevo davanti
architetti e non potenziali scrittori o
scrittrici che manipolavano lo spazio e
le strutture per farmi vedere Come
funzionavano i libri che amavano a quel
punto capì che l'architettura non è
questa disciplina distante io un po'
l'avevo praticata l'avevo studiata una
disciplina per esperti che dobbiamo
conoscere per poter comprendere
l'architettura noi la leggiamo da quando
siamo nati noi ci ci nasciamo dentro lo
spazio andiamo avanti per tutta la vita
ci siamo adesso lo facciamo
continuamente l'architettura è viva e
viva in noi
e ci parla continuamente
apriamo una finestra
Attraversiamo una soglia scendiamo
saliamo
[Musica]
ci sorprendiamo di fronte a una piazza
che ci si apre nel mezzo di un tessuto
urbano denso o un edificio alto alla
fine di una discesa oppure ci sediamo
sotto una cupola e sentiamo il peso del
vuoto Non del peso di ciò che è
costruito ma il peso di ciò che non c'è
Perché l'architettura la si osserva però
la leggiamo e l'assorbiamo con il corpo
in movimento e così colsi grazie a
questi ragazzi e ragazze 12 anni fa che
da un lato Sì ci sono
le interpretazioni la pioggia che fa il
ticchettio i personaggi che dobbiamo
immaginare Ma dall'altro queste
strutture esistono potevano essere
rappresentate visualizzate e costruite
a un certo punto mi imbatte in questa
citazione di Alice mundo
e lei dice una storia non è come una
strada da seguire è più come una casa
Entri e ci rimani per un po' la percorri
in lungo in largo e ti metti dove vuoi e
scopri il legame tra le stanze e
corridoio e come il mondo visto da
queste finestre appaia diverso e tu il
visitatore il lettore Se anche tu
diverso quando sei racchiuso in questi
spazi siano essi angusti o aperti poco
arredati o sfarzosi continui a
ritornarci e ogni volta la casa la
storia contiene di più di quello che hai
visto l'ultima volta
il bello per me di questa incredibile
citazione Trovata per caso e che da un
lato spiegava perfettamente la
sensazione sinestetica che io avevo
descritto gli studenti dall'altro dice
che queste strutture esistono perché chi
scrive sa che sta costruendo tutto
questo e allo stesso tempo vuol dire che
queste strutture possono essere
costruite e siamo noi ognuno di noi
singolarmente che le crea quando
incontra una storia perché è l'unico
modo per poterle
vivere
esplorare abitare
trovarcisi dentro andare e ritornare
E quindi capii che se da un lato
esisteva La visualizzazione dall'altro
esistevano anche le storie
Io sono 12 anni che ho la fortuna Quindi
grazie al laboratorio di architettura
letterario questa idea strana la
curiosità che ebbi di 12 anni fa di
visitare un sacco di luoghi di
architetture costruite da altre persone
ispirate a storie racconti di Alice
Munro Emy hempel Calvino Hemingway
e in ognuno di questi laboratori io vedo
persone che estraggono in qualche modo
dalle storie quella che era loro
interpretazione del loro funzionamento
della loro struttura e manipolano con
grande facilità questioni
architettoniche strutturali che io ho
studiato e ho avuto la difficoltà ogni
tanto di applicare e Questioni legate
alla letteratura la narrazione e il
confine tra le due discipline scompare
sono Un'unica cosa non esiste differenza
tra l'uno e l'altro
guardiamo per esempio
un racconto colline come elefanti
Bianche di
Ernest Hemingway che è una è una storia
nella quale Hemingway racconta di lui e
di lei
sono in una stazione stanno aspettando
un treno e discutono di una possibile di
un possibile
piccolo intervento che lei deve forse
fare
e che avrà un gigantesco effetto della
loro vita nel loro amore nella loro
relazione
Ecco sono due gruppi di studenti
studentesse di liceo e a destra il
gruppo di destra si è concentrato sul
peso della decisione il peso della
decisione incombe sul racconto su di
loro sulla storia sulla loro vita e
quindi hanno disegnato e progettato una
piazza che è un livello inferiore
rispetto a quello della città dove Noi
scendiamo lentamente e ci troviamo
questo peso che Grava sul tutto con dei
cavi in forte tensione che secondo loro
sono il segno del logorio del loro
rapporto e noi facciamo attenzione a
questa grande presenza a sinistra invece
ci sono delle ragazze che si Sono
concentrate
Sul rapporto tra loro due sull'amore
sull'amore che c'è tra di loro ed è al
centro lo pongono al centro come un
grande cilindro un grande edificio
attorno al quale c'è un altro edificio
circolare che lo attanaglia e quella è
la decisione che loro devo prendere che
loro devono prendere e tutto ciò si
poggia su una piazza
in pendenza che è abbassata dal peso di
tutto questo che secondo loro
rappresenta il senso di dubbio che
permane continuamente nella lettura
perché noi non sapremo alla fine che
cosa succede la cosa bella del lavoro a
sinistra
e che durante la produzione del plastico
c'erano gli architetti che aiutano chi
non è in grado di fare plastici che
anche chi fa architettura alle volte non
gli riesce così bene ma ci sono degli
architetti che aiutano e a un certo
punto si voleva spingere il gruppo a
creare degli edifici che fossero più
squadrati il concetto rimaneva lo stesso
Però magari l'edificio centrale era un
parallelepipedo quello intorno squadrato
sia insistito leggermente con l'idea
dell'estetica e a un certo punto la
ragazza dice Alt Fermi voi adulti che
avete questa idea squadrata inquadrata
dell'amore Noi abbiamo ancora 16/17 anni
Lui ancora vediamo l'amore tra due
persone come una cosa Continua con mille
possibilità senza sfaccettature abbiamo
come dire il tempo per arrivare a quello
momento di pausa e grande rivelazione
durante questo lavoro del laboratorio
che cosa facciamo noi apriamo una
finestra nel momento in cui le idee e i
pensieri e le intuizioni hanno ancora
una forma che non è verbale i nostri
pensieri non sono sempre attaccati alle
parole alle volte hanno una forma e gli
anni formativi forse gli anni formativi
di questi ragazzi che incontriamo e di
tantissimi altri sono proprio anni
formativi perché sono gli anni in cui le
idee prendono forme in cui le nostre
cose in cui crediamo le cose che
vogliamo le cose che ci piacciono
prendono forma e diventano qualche cosa
prima che forse noi adulti tristemente
come ci ha detto la ragazza li
Trasformiamo in contenuto l'idea può
essere vista e trattata come
Architettura Grazie all'architettura che
noi tutti conosciamo per produrre gli
edifici delle nostre idee per cui voi
ora siete qui grazie per essere venuti
perché voi avete le menti ancora
malleabili fluide che danno forma ai
vostri pensieri per cui continuate a
usarla in questo modo uscite affrontate
gli spazi che incontrate le storie
questioni della vostra vita e costruite
palazzi ed edifici e magari Mentre ne
costruirete di chissà quali e così belli
uno di questi sarà una gelateria così Io
vi vengo a trovare e ci prendiamo un bel
gelato Grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]